Good morning , John, it's Friday.
So we've been doing this stuff for eight years
now on You--hello there.
Hi.
Corndog.
Ahmm.
Yaahh.
Why are you--haaah.
Hm.
AAHH.
Okay.
That was weird.
I um--I was--aaaaaaah!
[sighs]
The universe apparently wants me to do something
not in this chair and with these books.
[music plays]
1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4...
Arrrghhhh!
I remember when I was a young man, my momma
took me to the store--
125 cm.
But no reason to stop there!
--my pants are too bright, too dark, too baggy,
too light--
Aughhh, auh, auh, auhhhh.
--whatever you choose will be right.
155 cm, everybody, 155 cm, now let's go for
another level, because you can't build a giant
tower and just leave it there.
You have to see how far you can go.
and the first time I read Thoreau--
Okay, Book of Merlin is on, which opens up
the opportunity for another thing to get stacked
on here.
It doesn't mean anything.
Let's go with this.
That I try not to say too much just with my
clothes.
Ohhhh!
Well, it had to happen.
The question is, can ya beat me?
So first I wanna apologize for the amount
of underwear that I showed while constructing
my book tower.
That was both unintentional and embarrassing
but I'm certainly not gonna go rebuild an
entire book tower just so I can go put on
a belt and do it so that you don't see the
clothes that happen to cover up my bottom.
Second, I made a book tower that was 155cm
tall, and I believe that that is not as tall
as a book tower can be, so I would like you
to beat me.
The five highest towers and the five most
stylin' towers will win a special gift package
sent directly to your house from me.
Rules: You cannot use any kind of adhesive
or clamps or anything that binds the books
together.
It has to be composed of loose books.
Rule number two: You cannot hurt yourself
or do anything that might cause you to hurt
yourself please.
Three: You can only use books, but you can
pool together books from multiple sources.
Four: You have to have a tape measure and
you have to measure in centimeters because
inches are dumb and I cannot believe that
we still use any kind of measurement system
that is not based on the numerical system
that we use of base-10.
Base-12?
Why are there 12 inches in a foot?
To enter, send a picture of your book tower,
with the subject 'Book Tower' and then the
height of your book tower in the subject line
to hankandjohn@gmail.com.
And lastly, it is time for the Nerdfighteria
Census.
This'll be the third annual, we've been doing
it since 2013, and the idea is just so that
the community can get to know itself better,
know what it is, know who it is, I can do
an analysis, know what you want from this.
We can better plan any future tour that we
might do so that we know where people are,
and this year, for the first time, we actually
talked to some researchers who are doing some
science and we had them put in a few questions
which will help them better understand the
world and the people in it, so that's cool.
It's not an insignificant thing, it takes
a little while to do, like 10-30 minutes,
but we really appreciate it when people do
do that, and there's a link in the description
if you wanna go and do it, so thank you, we
appreciate that.
Looking forward to seeing all your book towers
and, John, I'll see you on Tuesday.